Mehta is a statistician and a data miner
doesn't self-identify as a data
scientist and she's over in the UK to
give a couple of talks including the
Bank of England tomorrow and Imperial
College shortly afterwards and the
Imperial College talk will be an open
talk so you can register for that and I
think you'll mention a bit about that
later on and Metro is also the author of
data mining for dummies and so we're
going to have an interesting talk about
a process that's well known in other
fields but was new to me so I hope to be
educated thoroughly about our formal
methodology for doing some of our work
so please welcome meta good morning
let's warn everyone what we're going to
be speaking about so if it's not your
taste you can sneak out the back very
quickly I'm going to explain to you what
Chris diem is and where it's come from I
want to explain the phases of the
process and then I want to talk to you
to this group of people very
specifically about where Chris PM lies
today and why there are good reasons why
you may want to become involved with it
so who am I to tell you this it's been
mentioned I'm the author of data mining
for dummies and some other books I am a
data miner I don't use the term data
scientist some people call me that name
but I was trained classically as a
statistician and it was enough of a
challenge to get used to date a miner
answer and I have been doing hands-on
working data mining and in text mining
since the 1990s and that's a long time
for those fields I've done many
successful projects and in particular my
focus is on two things it's on helping
people actually make money from their
analysis and professionally I put food
on the table by working with folks like
you people who identify as data
scientists data miners statisticians web
analysts engineers
and any of a host of other data analysts
sort of titles technical titles learn to
communicate with everyone else because
many people cannot understand us so
Chris D M stands for cross industry
standard process for data mining and it
is the dominant process for data mining
where did it come from well the term
data mining has been in use for a long
time it's not really clear how long at
least since the early 90s as a very
informally used term in the 1960s people
used a lot of broad terms and largely in
a negative way things like data fishing
data diving and data mining might have
been in there too so the term is not so
new but data mining in its modern sense
and in the sense that I've been using it
for many years and wrote a book about it
it has been around since the early to
mid 90s now there was in 1989 a workshop
called knowledge in dated discovery and
these workshops continue to go on and
that was a seminal moment for data
mining in that at that time a broad
knowledge and data discovery is actually
kdd knowledge and discovery in databases
was defined as a kind of a linear
process and the term data mining may not
at that moment but soon thereafter began
to be used there as the narrow step in
it the algorithm step the usage has
changed a bit over time so in 1994 a the
first what I would call modern data
mining workbench
was created it was called Clementine and
if you're young you may only know
Clementine by the name it has today
which is IBM SPSS modeler because
integral solutions limited who first
created this got bought by SPSS SPSS got
bought by a IBM and so they gave it the
longest most awful sounding not at all
memorable name that they could and if
you meet today's IBM employees or
product users all products that used to
belong to SPSS are called SPSS so it's
very hard to understand which product
they're talking about they might be
talking about what used to be Clementine
I think we should just call it that the
product formerly known as Clementine or
they might be talking about any of a
number of other products so what was
important about this this positioned
data mining as something that business
people do people who are not trained as
statisticians not trained as programmers
but people who are experts in the work
that they do so that work might be
making a chemical factory work better
that work might be selling newspaper
subscriptions to you that work might be
running any kind of a business and I say
that loosely because the business might
in fact be a government operation or a
nonprofit but they're not expert data
analysts they're not expert programmers
they're not meant to be so how was it
possible to enable that group of people
to be making discoveries in data well
they got a graphic user interface that
was perfectly suited to them and it's
called a visual programming interface
and today you see them in other kinds of
tools as well and in the early versions
the algorithms
were available there were very strictly
the ones that were associated with data
mining so they were pattern-recognition
there were no traditional statistical
tools I think in the very first versions
soon thereafter people started using
this stuff and they realized we need to
define a process and by 2000 that
process had been defined how did it
happen
well a group of key data mining
organizations daimler-benz integral
Solutions Limited an NCR only one of
which is still called by that name today
said you know we're doing this we need a
process they they wanted something that
everyone could use no matter what tools
they used what industry they were in and
for that matter what budget they had so
they got funding from the European Union
and they formed a special interest group
and that special interest group
attracted over 200 organizations they
met in several places and they put
together this very nice step-by-step
guide to what you need to do to do data
mining and it was a much broader process
than just algorithms so already what
data mining was was redefined as let us
start by understanding a business
problem and going all the way to putting
out something that would help solve that
problem this uh this graph is graph it's
not really graph is it it's a diagram
this is not to be the best-known thing
about Christian it's so well known that
last week at another conference I saw
someone show this without the caption
explaining what it was without ever
referring to Chris p.m. I'm not even
sure that he was familiar with Chris
p.m. but he sure as heck knew this
diagram and when I say this diagram I
mean this exact diagram right so it's
it's become so popular that it's
floating around in places where it is
disk
connected from its original Association
in the sense of that particular project
and why is that happening well because
it's not only those of us who identify
as data miners who can use this process
and for you who identify as data
scientist is that true of most of you
I'm getting a Sunday morning having
having this process and thinking it
through is valuable to you because I can
tell you right now that there's not one
business person on earth who cares what
Python package or our package you are
using so this will help you to
communicate and think the way that the
folks who are paying would like you to
think so alright so we see there are six
phases business understanding data
understanding data preparation modeling
evaluation deployment let me talk
through very briefly those six phases
but let me take a second before I do
this is the most popular process among
data miners right I can give you poll
results I can also tell you the polls
are not entirely unbiased they're not
even close to unbiased but I have very
broad experience and I I know from that
as well this is the dominant process
there's really only one other well-known
process and that is proprietary to one
of the software manufacturers so this is
it folks it has these six phases and
while many many many people say we use
crisp TM what they mean is usually we're
aware that there are these six phases
and we kind of do something like that
they don't really take advantage of the
full depth of the process and often
that's because they haven't read any
more and I can understand that that's
not so easy because there's a wonderful
guide and it provides a lot of death and
it's 75 pages of small text so
not everybody who says they use Korea's
GM is really aware of everything it
involves so let me give you a flavor of
that so the first step is business
understanding and it sounds very simple
here is where you get a clear
understanding of the problem you're out
to solve how it impacts your
organization and your goals for
addressing it and there are four tasks
now identify your business goals assess
your situation define your data mining
goals and produce your project plan if I
substitute data science for data mining
do you do that it's only a rhetorical
question by getting a few knots on
getting a lot of no knots let me go a
little deeper
in fact Chris PM defines what tasks
should be going with it so there are
deliverables specific deliverables that
for just one identifying your business
goal you would have to give background
give give the broad goal of what your
organization is trying to accomplish and
very specific if at all possible with
something measure alike we want to
increase sales by 10% this year not all
sales sales related to the project and
then define how the results would be
measured so these deliverables might not
be very long but they're specific
deliverables that it's very important to
define and in fact just for the business
understanding phase there are 12
deliverables so what you just saw was
for the first task there are three we
can see that there are more in each task
some of them are short like the ones
I've just described but in fact three of
them are in depth we refine our in-depth
reports so in fact merely getting an
understanding of the business problem
that's good enough to go calls for you
to do a lot of things doing these things
means that you will understand clearly
what's actually valuable to management
before you go off and do all the work
because it is no fun to have that
experience who has ever done a lot of
work and then had
management's say this is not useful to
us at all yes only one person's
admitting but it's a home war hands are
going up yes because it it happens and
it happens a lot and I will not swear
that you can ever guarantee that a
manager will not at the end of
everything say we can't use this but it
will happen far less frequently if you
make the effort to do this all right now
I'm not going to drag you through every
deliverable of every phase but we have
six phases so after a significant amount
of effort to understand the problem
which is very valuable all right we go
on to understanding the data assessing
its quality describing it and I mean
describing every single variable or
field if that's the term you prefer and
assessing what's there how good is it
what does it look like data preparation
data preparation takes what percentage
of the time a very big percentage of the
time some people say 80 I've heard
plenty of people say it takes them more
than 90 I hear people saying oh it's
less than half the time our data is good
yeah I don't believe I mean they I
believe they spend less than half their
time on it but I don't believe their
results are good and then modeling the
fun part
then the modeling yes now in data mining
we cheat let me make this clear data
mining is statistics for cheaters this
is part of how it's made accessible to
business people now it's important to
say this I do not believe and most
experienced data miners do not believe
you should dive into data mining as a
business person with no training and
what's more I don't believe you should
dive into data mining as a data
scientist or a status
with no training it's a different style
but when we talk about training I'm
talking about a few days of training not
a few years of training so you can't
models and the problem then is this that
the way that data miners use all the
modeling tools available to them it's
not backed up by theory it's not backed
up by theory at all why because you're
using available data so we haven't
sampled carefully to get what's relevant
you're not checking that the assumptions
behind the algorithm are actually met
and even worse data miners really like
ensemble models and maybe you really
like ensemble models too and who am I to
tell you no but I will certainly tell
you this there's absolutely no theory to
support the use of your ensemble model
so what do you have to do you have to
test and test and test and that's
evaluation so now that you've gotten
your data ready you've created some
models that you think survive tests you
deploy them you put them out into the
everyday business contexts and all of
this is a cycle and at every step at
every phase there are steps you should
take we call them tasks in Christian and
each task may have several deliverables
in fact even more deliverables than are
described in the step-by-step guide
because for reasons I've never
understood it doesn't describe the
datasets as a deliverable but you better
be delivering those two so why would you
want to use this elaborate process for
doing your work it is in fact practical
the idea is not hard to understand it's
always always tied to a business problem
and that very first step of business
understanding is one where most analysts
and it really does not matter what you
call yourself a data scientist a web
analyst a statistician in fact most data
analysts are very weak on understanding
and explaining why their work is
relevant to the business and in fact
often fail to make work relevant to the
business from the managers viewpoint
because not enough time is put into this
it's really fun to jump into modeling
and it really means nothing to
management now this is common across
just the widest possible swath of let's
say our kind I've I've done talks or
entire workshops for students from some
of the most respected analytics graduate
programs in the United States I've done
them for working analysts with anything
from very little experience up to folks
who came in and said well I've written a
book too and they have but when we ask
them to explain what they've done in
human terms most have a very hard time
with it and it's it's worrisome to me
that I often ask people all right well
but what does the data represent who are
the people what problem are they facing
that really more often than not
analysts are not able to turn it around
that way now I think it's a little
harder because when I ask them they're
at work or they're at school I think if
you were home well not home maybe home
with a glass of wine or you know in the
pub with a beer you would have a much
easier time
and it might be how you talked about it
in the first place but there's something
about being in the workplace and telling
human stories that is less comfortable
so having thought it through before you
start means that when you're explaining
at the other end you're going to do it
better it also ensures that your work is
done thoroughly and when I say
thoroughly it means you don't work alone
you're working with a lot of
constituents from a lot of different
viewpoints right you'll work with IT
people we want to know why should they
let you into the data you'll work with
managers who want to know why they
should be paying you or listening to you
and you may work with a whole host of
subject matter experts and they need to
feel that you are worth their time also
on the other hand they may feel you're
worth their time they may not understand
what you want to know and if you can't
explain it to them they're not going to
give you the right information this is
evergreen right it was defined by people
who call themselves data miners so what
with the exception that you might care
more about using models that actually
have a theoretical basis before you
choose your techniques every single
thing that goes on in here could go on
and you could call yourself a data
scientist a statistician or any of a
host of other analysts titles and it's
never going to change and hey it's free
so it's there for you to discover and
take advantage of and very flexible so
you can adapt it to your particular
needs as I said it's popular it's used
around the world it's used even by
people who don't call themselves data
miners but it's not necessarily done
well and that is a big concern it's not
necessarily done well
so we have a big constituency but we
don't have a really great organization
behind this right now that special
interest group brought together so many
organizations and they really put in a
lot of work took a couple of years to
produce the step by step data mining
guide and it was a very interesting
process because I I was at the time
working with some of the people who were
involved so you know what I know is
across this wide range of industries and
roles people might have liked different
methods different tools but their
process was very similar so there was
tremendous agreement on that but once
the document was created no more funding
no commercial interests really pushing
it the organization quietly dissolved
and that's created a lot of problems so
there are problems with distribution
problems because there's a lack of
education and because there is no
institution or has not been behind
Christian so what's gone on now is that
lots of people use the term lots of
products have some elements of Christian
built in but not all the elements okay
so there's a document and it's
absolutely free have fun finding it
because it does not come up first in the
Google results it's it's on the IBM
website somewhere and it's even I have
trouble finding it okay and I know
exactly what I'm looking for and where
it's going to be and I still have
trouble finding it uh it is as I said 75
pages long and the type is not very big
and then if you get it it's not really
clear can you share it can you give it
to other people
if you want to quote from it whose
permission would you ask none of this is
clear so this has been problematic so
there's been a lot of distribution of
the general ideas but getting into the
details that's been weak ok so I would
say that that was weak from 2000 when
the document came out until last year
and still needs improvement a lot of
books have mentioned it not not many go
into depth a lot of tools bring in some
bit of it a broader education problem is
that let's say you want to learn about
this live classes are hard to come by
why our live class is hard to come by
well follow the money right someone
needs to pay for a live class who who
owns the dominant products IBM now owns
the dominant data mining product and IBM
doesn't do training anymore okay in case
you weren't aware of that IBM does not
do training anymore so that means that
and their partners have to do training
ok well that sounds good except IBM
closes the sale on the software and then
have fun meeting apart they'll introduce
you but if you don't know if you're
going to get training business you're
not going to invest in developing it so
there are a few partners doing training
not very many not many people SAS and
and each of the other somewhat dominant
data mining companies they do some
training but you know what the training
is it's mostly how to use this software
it's not what's a good data mining
process not many classes at schools
there are many web resources but they're
not that great and the books usually
only touch on it and they can get very
academic except that there's this new
book which boils it down so so that was
a big mission of mine when I set out to
write data mining for dummies which
describes Chris p.m. in 25 pages of
your type so that's a step one book is
not going to meet everybody's needs you
know so people are going to need more
more details slanted for their
particular approach so maybe there's a
need for a book for Python data expert
to have Christian explain in the flavor
that suit suits you perfectly and maybe
one of you is the person to write it
no organization because there's no
financial interest in it historically
but there's a change there too is that
last year the Society of data miners was
founded and it was founded by four very
experienced data miners who happen to
live right around here so the
headquarters of the Society of data
miners is right here in London and it's
now the focal point the institution
that's positioned right to take Crispian
forward and see that we do start getting
the education that we need and we do
enhance the existing document with more
examples and start seeing that there are
more books more web resources that
provide the professional slant that
suits different kinds of users the
language that suits different kinds of
users the level of death that suits
different types of users so for the PI
data community what's the challenge the
challenge in your work is always to
produce value for your employers or
clients to have a good work process
that's efficient and effective and also
to be perceived as someone who is doing
those things because if you are not
perceived as providing value in doing so
efficiently what's going to happen to
you
not the ideal things Chris VM will
provide value by assuring that you're
doing something that's relevant
it'll maximize the chance of producing a
positive ROI which in fact is a lot
rarer in analytics than it ought to be
in text analytics I have actually seen
poll results from a pretty good poll
which still shows and has shown for
years that the majority of people who
enter into text analytics do not break
even I have never been able to find any
kind of good numbers on analytics in
general I don't think it's quite as bad
but in fact many people don't break even
and they don't break even primarily for
just one reason they never made a plan
to break even in fact most of the
success stories I should say most that's
going too far
but many success stories that you hear
for any kind of analytics they are
backfilled by which I mean we played
around with analytics and then we've got
to justify what we did so we're going to
find any success in the business that
was in any way tied to data analysis and
we're going to claim that and that's
baloney you don't have positive our way
unless you start it off with a defined
goal and in fact have measurable
positive returns by that goal and let me
give you a little hint that managers
don't tell you if you're about to
propose a project and you need to show
how it's going to produce benefits ah as
an analyst always think ooh the big
benefits are in increasing revenue do
not make your business case on
increasing revenue make your business
case
on decreasing costs and you're more
likely to sell your project because
management believes you can decrease
cost they don't believe you can increase
revenue and the political complexity of
deploying something to increase revenue
is much greater so they may also know
that they can't execute on that that has
to be your secondary benefit hi and
what's more use this process you're
going to you're going to document better
you're going to make sure you've done
the steps so you're going to you're
going to protect your own role and
you're going to protect the work that
you've done and maintain that
intellectual property for yourself your
client your employer something that data
analysts are generally weak on the
process is going to ensure that you work
in an efficient and consistent manner
and as I said that you documents so this
is not big and if you do it this way
because you will have thought through
what am i doing why am i doing it how is
it relevant to the business you're going
to be understood better you're going to
be able to demonstrate value better and
that means that you just might get
decision-makers to do something ok
they'll be more willing to respect what
you've said and act upon it and really
what what is the point of what we do if
no one will act upon it quick one who
here has the power to take action on
every recommendation you make is it you
raise your hand if you can take all the
actions no nobody's hit yeah usually one
tentative hand goes up and then comes
back down so if we cannot influence
management our work is just work it's
not productive work so we've got an
opportunity all right you can you can
read about Chris p.m. so you can
download the Christian step-by-step data
mining guide which I now realize I
forgot to put the link to in here
but I'll send it to floor in and and it
will get round or you can write me
personally I'm made to brown at Maita
brown comm and I have piles of cards you
can try googling just by that name tell
me what you get you can read the book
you don't need to buy it go ask your
library to get it I understand from what
I can tell it's only in eight libraries
in the UK so far so nag your library
it's cheap and yeah you can buy it and I
will not object and there is more
information out there be a little
cautious about what you read and judging
the source and the quality but there is
more out there you can learn from people
who've been involved in data mining for
a long time by getting involved with the
Society of data miners again their base
right here and it is a very young and
very informal organization right now
andrey buddies welcome everybody will
always be welcome but everybody is
really welcome right now and you can
adapt this to your particular working
situation in style so please come you
know and lead among your profession the
use of crispy m and take it forward you
can reach Society of data miners through
their website sack da morgue it is not
the most stunning looking website you've
ever seen but there's a there's a con
there's contact information there and
you can tell them that I sent you
everybody the founding committee knows
who I am I am the actually other than
the four guys who founded it I am the
first member of the Society of data
miners I was just waiting for them to
finish it up and so and at least one of
them has worked with me for many years
and tell them you're interested in Chris
p.m. you want to learn more you want to
get involved and and I have spoken
personally with the founding chairman
and told him this is my call to action
and confirmed that yes they can get in
touch with him personally his name is
Tom cabeza
and if you look him up you'll discover
his nine laws of data mining which are
also very cool and again where to find
the book is here where to find me so
that's all in the slide deck which
you're going to distribute yes Thank You
Ian and if your questions I'm very happy
to answer yes sir I'm going directly to
the gentleman with the loud shirts I
come from software development
background and this feels to me a bit
like analogous to waterfall method which
is as it has come to be realized in
software development is the worst way to
develop software mm-hm
it's based on the principle that the
customer knows what they want to write
at the start you give it to them and
they realize that's not what they want
after all ok and feels to me that this
you have to write half a dozen or more
reports before you even look at the data
whereas looking at the data may give you
more information about the business may
give the business more information about
the business ok all right let's how you
respond to that first it is very
offensive to data analysts to tell them
you have to write things down and you
have to write reports
I know tough because your managers are
not not high level minute not the guys
who guys and gals who control the money
are not going to sit and spend time with
us they will not so things must be
written for them and you know what when
I say they're written for them they're
really written for the person one level
below them because they don't read this
stuff either right so we write this
stuff and yes you do write it down
primarily for the benefit of the person
who reports to the manager controlling
the money so that that person can first
get an
overview and know what to think and say
quickly and second when question go back
into depth and get more information all
of these processes are a back and forth
now I hear what you're saying it looks
it's a cycle okay so none of it in fact
is straight round it may not be well
represented so it does all go back and
forth and yet it is in fact the way that
business works so I know what you're
thinking when we're thinking of the you
know right I'm blanking on the chairman
that those iterative development with
the two people working together and all
of this okay agile agile the next week
agile agile is the term that I was
looking for though all right and it
doesn't feel that way and by the way no
one on earth puts two data analysts
working next to one another in any
business context I know you're lucky to
get one person so is it a little
different style it is it is all about
and forth so it's not a straight line at
all but at the same time is it just like
an agile or or any of the similar
processes it is not I I think it could
be a could it be adapted to that yes but
not so much that you don't have to write
things down and you fly by the seat of
your pants forget it you're not going to
get managers to sit and look at what
you're doing playing along in analysis
like that it it is absolutely
unrealistic and and why is that
different from the software because the
locate the place in the organization
where people look at your software is
that the user level and there you might
be willing to look every day or every
few days but and this you're asking
management to take an action management
to commit resources and just to give an
example I heard a talk last week by a
very very high level expert analyst not
someone down at the ground level but it
you know
a vice-president level person who runs
an entire team of managers at a very
very important multinational corporation
and he talked about being asked a few
days before the United States
Thanksgiving holiday which is a huge
holiday should produce a certain
analysis right so he you know he was
working nights and he produced his nice
brief 10 slide presentation and he sent
it to the executive they hadn't heard
back so he went you know right before
the holiday to check and the man looked
at him and said it's 7 p.m. Thanksgiving
is tomorrow boil it down to one phrase
yes right I said one phrase that's the
amount of time he was actually willing
to put in on it
so you simply do not have the audience
who's going to be engaged with you all
the way through as you would in an agile
software development process time for
one more question
hi great talks thank you I would ask you
or you said you you you are a
statistician and data miner and
referring for example formation learning
area there is a really horrible thing
happening here
yeah these all these nonlinear models
and I see lots of cases when people use
nonlinear models this very complex
hypothesis on who is where where lots of
features on very small datasets and
things like goggle is doing this more
popular even and people don't care about
some public challenges dimensions or
mess but they have an excuse they said I
have done a cross validation so like
never done 50k fault validation and it
is ok ok all right so this makes sure
I'm just gonna repeat the question on
that one all right so the question is
look right so I've talked about data
miners and data miners cheap right they
use they use algorithms that are
completely inappropriate to the
situation and and then they get
something that looks good and then in
example you described they say it's fine
because I've done cross-validation
that's not enough testing so what do I
mean when I say that data miners test
test test it means first of all the data
miners hold out some data and don't use
it to build models and if you're lucky
you hold out several spare datasets if
you have enough data and you try what
you've done against these several sets
that were not used to develop the model
and see if it still works it will
usually fall apart right there if it
still holds up you must feel tests on a
small scale okay so field testing I mean
you have to go out into the world and
see if it still works in a new situation
with new data that never existed before
and only if it gets through all of that
have you really got something that you
can you can then say yeah we're going to
deploy this across an organization and
use it in everyday business just saying
it cross validates is not enough even
for a data miner